yo what's up guys pretty sure hey great
start and this is the next the eighth
that one say the eighth episode in my
minecraft oh no no no no no fire for you
in my minecraft hair bond survive or
Harrow Bryn sorry Survival Series and
today a problem be as super invigorating
episode I want to do some oh really oh I
know their weight I was doing some
slight renovations in my house what the
heck you see I made this little better
um exactly grab some of this thing up
through my arrows in your hair bows oh
so hey come on that hope hope he's
coming die i'm gonna bet my hard money
study tied oh he didn't I don't know is
that alright this is definitely
something that I have to clean up that
area and I have to make this accessible
like this just looks terrible so we is
well that's from that creeper explosion
we're going to clean up some stone yeah
there's probably going to be a tad bit
more maintenance so I'm apologies if you
do not enjoy it at that stuff we will
get another adventure soon enough don't
worry ok patch that up and then here i
wanna just put some wood so that look
good
oh my god works good I can patch the
rest of the stone Humberstone a patch
patch patch hmm I just gotta wait for it
to the covenants have this process go a
tad bit faster it's not once we will
we're at it so I'm thinking I should
make a farm for the wheats you'll do the
dev a hoe I do not think I do so let's
get so let's keep some of this iron with
me and makes teach and make hail think I
have a bucket I don't really need milk
for anything so I'm going to turn that
into stuff fences we're going to want
some fences definitely i'm just going to
need more fun sec what
this is a I'm going to say this is a
faster way this is 17 fences probably
won't be enough mostly need fence gates
but whatever i also need my shish
caution each each phase person we're
going to need more torches ah ah cold
there we go ok so we're don't want to
make the farm oh lets me down here where
it's already near water source it did it
did I just want to do that make it all
dirty least yeah farm is definitely like
a necessity and um living yeah and I
don't wanna be down here let's flatten I
and I'd what to do so I get a little bit
of cough I'll make I'm going to end up
making it there anyways
yeah hmm hmm should you like this that
will go four blocks and your phone right
there I would make more I can make
longer putts show with that yeah what's
the heck there we go freaky water ash
mega infinite water supply go one more
haha we've done it hurts now we're going
to need that is going to be fun to a oh
you can hum grounds in the water could
you be like a wall around this
do-do-do-do-do-do-do game definitely i
have to build some sort of all but for
now let's plant seeds i can jump on this
ground but how do they remove seed
planting roses mm-hmm i guess i did now
a wall like have 17 fence pieces might
as well do something that
hmm you covered from both sides that's
deep dude Wow yeah I'm not going to have
ammo too much else I can have fences
city much else I mean much more fences
could do cobble stone fences should I do
that let's take a look to see how it
looks these tacky you just in case we'll
take the rest of that sack now use a
stone to patch up my ground my ground
just uh this stuff is that it yeah
that's it it looks it looks good all
right I don't IT let's experiment with
some cobblestone also called something
that's a lot you got a lot easier to
make it I think I don't know so let's
get shopping is rather relatively fast
so we should will be good I should do
cobblestone walls and write the other
place is that look good yeah it looks
good I'm until that don't show it blue
blue blue to do dude I think it's
inspector gadget indeed
now we sprint to place they need us up
no my diamonds just going to do this
right now get over with damn pic e let's
make six seven eight and also I can't
make a 40 that's way more than enough
but it will hey the fancy stuff goes in
there if 40 is probably way more than us
but oh well and you cannot make a you
can't make gates also negates or to my
knowledge you can't
literature root 2 root yes im doin's
right
we just go in there and examiner farm
will be able to expand it in multiple
ways later but we need torches so toes
boo boo doo doo doo Roo to to do do do
do a 2020 perfect shot torch torch torch
torch torch torch put towards
torch torch torch I think I should we
get All Right see well for the night
will block it off what they had no I
didn't mean to do that and we just go in
there and open it whatever we want to we
got on the birch Albert tree virtually
your woods give your settings in the
morning and more than time yeah actually
that should be little enough going on
tour too much about stuff so this look
good yeah this looks good we don't want
have to worry too much about stuff ah so
awesome too much about stuff attacking
it from above we should be alright he in
that account now let's do some
assortments
and I want you and I consider you to be
in a chest that is some honey hole like
I'm just going to do a quick check I
think a little longer they do to fritter
doesn't be over yes it's been a very
pretty freaking boring video so
apologies apologies if it's tad bit
bored boom all right now what I want to
do what I let's do I have another little
I haven't used this for anything hmm
i'll change the grounds I don't want it
to be dirt hey Calv a sound from the
Harley a creeper explosion that I
covered up
Oh cold sorry but which one of the hi
there it's a good way to get XP and you
actually get you get coal from it so I
like me some coal never have too much
coal you might tell yourself you can I
too much coal but then you run out of
calling you feel coal mine and coal
mining is terrible okay we got over
stuff to make sure no mobs spawn here
just off the way your chance plop plop
now what should I make this ground out
of two stone bricks Moss stone you'll
save them awesome for them special
chiseled sandstone sad stone I breaks
and son it just sanson right yeah it's a
really fast break I can make it us and
so that'd be like too bright l don't
have enough
looks like cool enough smooth Oh smooth
sense and what's the difference and the
difference is the sides which I'm not
going to see so what I could use that
for the other blocks dirt and then yeah
it's like a sad thing this doesn't know
what I'm going to use for it use it for
but it looks good hold together yeah I
like it we're keeping it no one should
hit yes I really oh my gosh this girl to
killing me what should i do I start a
farm I got so the building situation hmm
let's go look for a place and go mine
like a cavern I have a plethora of
torches I food good armor I noticed that
I was testing some himself out and
creative and really it's not go that way
really the only way to survive a creeper
shot directly let's go off here the only
way to be like like directly I mean like
when you're like two inches from the
creeper which they they stop farther
away from you so you usually go have to
worry about that but if you're just
closed for some reason the only way to
stop that like to not die from that is
to have insane like diamond dog around
so yeah
that's going to be tough you skeleton
drop me some arrows how Bad's got one
yeah offer in the water skeletons rack
you so hard okay don't go in the water
anymore hi you're the one now new up i'm
back the water oh no one right there we
go arrows i called that so good we're
gonna have to end the video with like
mid search arun octopus when I never I
this free octopi at themselves I see
that over creeper might have might have
nope I was hallucinating I was on damn
hallucinogens is there anything him her
re noises nothing well usually eerie
noise means cave so check out it just
checking out will do to do checking it
out it also apologies if you can expect
in hair over and burn they told you it
was gonna be in these stabbing updated
the mod could always uh down upgrade my
uh my version of Minecraft and it's
possibility
due to due to funds in coal for cave
okay I don't like this place anymore
nope ah I went into this video be like I
want to make a short video it's like I'm
pretty sure it's turned into a long
video but so you guys seem to like the
videos so tonight me assuming you like
it when it's longer hmm that's what she
said no no what he said bailed out I
don't know nevermind i'm not good at
those so I'll attend to gravel gravel
sit gateway to the jungle biome so I
could get some slobs on some slabs
evolution be picking this call hmm yo la
15 y is accomplished fish accomplished
take you up let's get ash lime or which
is hunt that'd be cool I don't know have
I explore this at all yet don't think so
i'm going to flying around probably
remember scene but let's get these
things all rights yeah I think I'll
ankle in the video here alright guys
well their scent of you it's in the
video proper I five I will be on droid
this view my name is receipt if you're
new to my channel and subscribe for more
stuff like this if you're not new then
keep up the support and if you got the
fan of this who give me that if you have
to end this video then make sure you
leave a like comment subscribe has
already said okay bye